>> TENBERG: Hello, my name is Paul Tenberg.
I’m a director of business development for
Queplix. Queplix is an enterprise software
application vendor. We have suite of front
office automation solutions that range from
CRM to customer care, HR, IT help desks, and
a whole lot of full featured enterprise solutions.
We also have a set of tools that can crawl
through your legacy applications that are
not--no longer supported by vendors, and we
have an ability to extract business objects
out of those structured databases. And out
of those business objects we can create applications
based on JE2E platform that can be put into
a legacy-ready JE2E architecture. We also
work with Google to enable structured [INDISTINCT]
enterprise search. In other words, we can
search through various legacy applications
or DBMS types of applications and extract
also synthetic business objects and enable
universal search [INDISTINCT] applications.
And we work in conjunction with Google Search
Appliance to do that. Google Search Appliance
is very good in searching, of course, unstructured
data and we provide the structured data capability.
>> YASKIN: Yes. As Paul mentioned the application
is based on the GWT. The legacy conversion
application process is basically converting
the entire people [INDISTINCT] or remedy or
vent of application. It’s a GWT-based collection
of screens. We had to create our own library
for GWT. We’re using a lot of out-of-the-box
components; data widgets, UI widgets, but
we also created a whole library of additional
components to match what legacy application
had. So we’re creating a variety of UI elements
to represent the data in a certain way that
people are used to looking at the legacy applications.
>> MALE: Can you tell me a little bit about
how you came about in choosing, I mean, what
were the technical reasons in choosing GWT?
>> YASKIN: Sure. Yeah. One big primary reason
we chose GWT over competing frameworks, in
GWT, we believe we took a long time trying
to evaluate. We had even experienced in house
with frameworks like Dojo for example and
it took us a while to make that call. But
then once we established that we are a Java
shop and we used to just start off company
at that time, I think it was a no-brainer
for us because we all speak Java in our daily
life; we eat, breathe Java. And choosing GWT
because it allows us to write everything in
pure Java code and not having to deal with
the JavaScript and inter-browser compatibilities,
it was pretty straight choice for us, so that
was a winner. We never looked back.
>> MALE: So, as developers, we really value
if can share war stories and lessons for technical
challenges. Can you tell us about one particular
difficult period of development that you faced
and how you approached that technical challenge?
>> YASKIN: Sure. When we started, I think
we were one of the very first large scale
enterprise apps that was using GWT. And we
have pretty large customers like in the Fortune
500 range with 30,000 seats deployments each.
And one of the first challenges I think we
came across was lack of widgets. And, you
know, we, I guess, have that problem is a
little bit unique to us because, again, we’re
converting legacy apps and they all look a
little bit different. And in our case, we
have to make our GWT based app look almost
identical to the legacy systems to minimize
user retraining. So we were right away faced
with the lack of libraries offering various
UI widgets, so we had to create our own. That
took some time but now it’s open source;
it’s available to everybody who is using
GWT. So we're happy to contribute to the community.
That was one thing. Also, not being able to
use debugger in Chrome and we advertise Chrome
all over the place, so it’s just so much
faster. The bugger did not work to the same
degree in Chrome as it did in other browsers
like IE, so few challenges like that but I
think the benefits outweighed the challenges
that we’ve come across so far using GWT.
>> MALE: Three more questions.
>> YASKIN: Sure.
>> MALE: So what are the three top features
you like best about GWT?
>> YASKIN: Top three features, well, Java,
Java, Java. How about that? You know, writing
in Java and straight Java, pure Java code
is probably our top three benefits that we
got out of GWT. Not having to deal with the
clients’ side with the front end probably
took away 80 percent of time that we had to
spend otherwise. Browser compatibility probably
is another thing that just by writing pure
Java code you’ll eliminate all the things
that we struggled with in our framework which
we used before GWT. So I would say those three
probably top.
>> MALE: Okay. So where did you feel GWT being...?
>> YASKIN: I think there’s a lot of things
could be done to the debugger still. We still
see a lot of improvement there. Other than
that, we're just excited to get the new version
every time it comes out. We see a lot of improvement
in each version.
>> MALE: Last question.
>> YASKIN: Sure.
>> MALE: How long did it take your team to
build the first out of your application of
GWT and how many team developers from the
team?
>> YASKIN: Yeah. We have team dedicated to
GWT development of UI. The team is about eight
to ten people right now. Initial version,
a GWT-based version was out in three--three
to four months, so it’s fairly fast even
to start up company that we used to be. It’s
fairly fast considering our customer is a
pretty large organization. Okay. So, we’re
very excited about using GWT. All right. Thank
you.